you say cyrus et bienvenue dans ce coup
de fil on a tous une petite fourmi ça
peut aller l'arachnophobie ali vo phobie
la peur des idées mieux vaut pas qu'ils
sortent de laquelle je suis là en
passant par la vie trop kozo phobie la
peur des bicyclettes
mais comment peut naître une phobie une
des personnes qui nous a aidés à avoir
des éléments de réponse à cette question
c'est un scientifique a fait une
expérience c'est l'expérience des chiens
de pavlov c'est un scientifique russe
qui a fait un expérience en 1889 sur le
conditionnement classique
c'est un concept du biorythme le pilat
lloris c'est la science de comportement
c'est un courant de pensée en
psychologie
l'expérience est plutôt simple en roulis
à des événements qui vont entraîner des
réactions chez les organismes vivants
ces événements on les appelle stimulus
il ya plusieurs types de stimulus déjà
le stimulus neutre il n'entraîne aucune
réaction prédéfinis par exemple si je
fait sonner une cloche et va rien se
passer sur son organisme non c'est pas
vrai des falkland heureusement j'étais
passionné meilleure blague
il est aussi le stimulus inconditionnels
qui entraîne une réponse inconditionnel
c'est une réponse qui n'a pas appris que
l'ordre de reflex c'est par exemple si
je te souffle dans les yeux tu vas aller
fermer automatiquement hockey maman
qu'on a les bases passons à l'expérience
ou prochain donc ça c'est sky le chien
boxer dédicaces qui ne ressentent pas du
tout aux chapeaux blancs père quand le
chien perçoit de la nourriture il
sécrète beaucoup de salive la glande
salivaire fonctionne à fond donc la
perception de nourriture c'est un
stimulus inconditionnelle avec pour
réponse inconditionnels la sécrétion de
salive
sauf que pavlov barrage était juste
avant un son de cloche à chaque fois
qu'ils donnent de la bouffe c'est un
stimulus neutre le stimulus neutre doit
se trouver à avant le stimulus
inconditionnel attention il fait
l'expérience plein de fois si bien qu'au
bout d'un moment le son de cloche à lui
tout seul sans la bouffe déclenché la
sécrétion de salive
c'est donc devenu un stimulus
conditionnelle et la sécrétion de salive
et dans ce cas une réponse
conditionnelle pavlov a donc à ce
moment-là réussi à conditionner un chien
et l'aurait pu faire avec de l'air sera
donné de l'air conditionné
je précise qu'en vrai c'est un peu moins
glamour que ça sert en fait ils
tranchent l'ajout du chien tu vois il
ouvre bien aimé un tuyau il visse le
tuyau vous récupérez la salive du chien
et au lieu de donner de la bouffe
balance de la viande en poudre donc vive
le respect de l'animal
je vous laisse imaginer comment il
promène son chien et le conditionnement
marche aussi avec les hommes comme le
montre l'expérience du petit alors en
gros il ya un professeur qui s'appelle
le professeur watson qui va donner une
soul et blanches un gosse de trois ans
qui va jouer sauf que le cos il déteste
voit le bruit de deux règles qui
s'entrechoquent des tests faisant et ben
en fait à chaque fois que le coach va
voir la souris watson bim
il envoie un gros sont dégueulasses dans
la tête et du cou le gosse pas développé
une phobie des souris blanches et même
une phobie de tout ce qui a un pelage
blanc et même une phobie des masques de
père noël
1 on appelle ça la généralisation c'est
en fait tu va étendre ce tu veux le
stimulus conditionnelle albert honte à
acheter un nouvel ordinateur
a bercy c'est trop
albert ça n'a pas l'air d'aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le conditionnement est peut être plus ou
moins fort et on peut même le perdre
avec par exemple la désensibilisation
systématique en gros c'est une technique
qui va consister à travailler sur ta
réponse conditionnelle pour la changer
petit à petit face au stimulus
conditionnelle de plus en plus fort de
sorte à ne plus avoir de problèmes face
à ce stimulus au final le
conditionnement classique on y fait face
inconsciemment tous les jours c'est
quand par exemple tu vas entendre la
musique de ton réveil en pleine bulle la
journée et que ça va donner un petit
coup de stress et d'anxiété
c'est ce qui peut arriver dans les pubs
aussi on peut associer le nom d'un
produit avec une sensation de bien-être
dans le cas de cette pub on n'est
finalement pas très loin de l'expérience
des chiens de pavlov
c'est aussi pour ça que le
conditionnement classique peut être
vivement critiquée c'est par exemple le
cas dans orange mécanique de stanley
kubrick ou on réhabilite alex grâce à un
conditionnement hardcore
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah alors pas vous est conditionné en
quelques minutes bien a priori non déjà
parce que quatre minutes c'est très
short et en plus vous avez dû peut-être
comprendre mon petit manège et prendre
conscience de ce que j'essayais de faire
et quand on en prend conscience c'est
une autre paire de manches c'est plus de
la psycho que de la philo certes mais ça
touche à l'analyse et la compréhension
des mécanismes de l'homme
est ce un truc que j'adore donc tout ce
que j'adore mais moi j'aurais voulu
partager remarquer d'ailleurs qu'est ce
qu'on vient de voir peut s'opposer à la
vidéo 4 sur l'existentialisme puisque 6
par rapport à certaines choses on est
conditionné et qu'on suit finalement une
loi de action réaction et dans quelque
part on est un petit peu en jeu nos
libertés je vous laisse réfléchir là
dessus et je vous envoie du loch et de
la piste